five days after i got my license i was
driving from the phillipsburg mall and i
went to go buy baseball cards to make
some money and i dragged two of my
friends but my buddy's like holy [ __ ]
i'm so late to get home he's like
freaking out so i'm like [ __ ] we're in
the country and there's a car in front
of me that is going four and i'm scared
to like go around him i've been driving
for four minutes and the guy's like
please and i'm like [ __ ] okay so i go
around it and my third friend goes oh
[ __ ] that's mr wilson mr wilson's my
neighbor [ __ ] mr wilson's gonna tell on
me put my foot to the pedal and go fast
roll through this stop sign and sure
enough a cop stand pulls me over comes
up and he sees a bunch of what he thinks
are beers this was during my drink
stewart's root beer 24 7. he's like what
the [ __ ] is that i'm like oh stewards
don't pick it up you know it's the whole
thing i'm winning him over doing my
thing all of a sudden the guy i passed
stops tells the cop that i'm crazy
reckless almost hit him cop freaks on me
takes me home wants to talk to my mother
i ring the doorbell my sister answers
looks and has a huge smile